We are now ready to find the most likely
hidden path in an HMM, and it corresponds
to the following decoding problem that
asks us to find the optimal hidden path.
The input is emitted string and
an HMM defined by four objects:
alphabet, the set of states,
the matrix of transition probabilities,
and the matrix of emission probabilities.
And the output is a hidden pass pi that
maximizes the probability of x and pi.
Pr(x,pi), as we saw,
is equal to the product
Pr(x|pi) * Pr(pi),
and it is the product of n terms,
each term being the product of
emission probability and transition
probability as described in the slide.
To solve the decoding problem,
we will try to build a Manhattan
graph in such a way that every path
in this graph will correspond to
a hidden path in the HMM and vice versa:
every hidden path in the HMM will
correspond to a path in the built Manhattan.
For the coin flipping HMM
with this HMM diagram,
we will construct a Manhattan
consisting of two rows and
n columns,
where n is the number emitted symbols.
In this case, we'll also add source and
sink nodes to the beginning and
to the end of the resulting
directed acyclic graph,
and for the HMMs that emitted
the string of symbols F B B B F F,
we will construct the following path
through the Manhattan right here.
And you see that for
every string of emitted symbols,
we can construct the path in
the corresponding Manhattan.
For a little bit more complex
HMM consisting of three states,
our Manhattan will be built
of three rows and n columns.
Generally, if we have a HMM with k states,
there will k rows in this Manhattan.
As before, we will add start and
end states and
note that in difference from
the Alignment Manhattan,
when we had just three
directions from every node,
in the Decoding Manhattan
we have many directions:
anything that goes to the east works
in this newly built Manhattan.
We now need to define
the weights of edges in
the newly built Manhattan graph
for an HMM.
Let's consider an edge that starts
in column i-1 in state l and
connects it to the node corresponding
to state k in the column i.
We will refer to this edge as (l,k,i-1).
Now, this edge corresponds to
transitioning from state l
to state k with probability transition_(l,k),
and it also corresponds to emitting
the symbol xi from the state k.
And therefore, we define the weight
of this edge as weight_(l,k,i-pi),
and it is equal to the product
of the emission probability
of emitting symbol xi
from state k multiplied
by the transition probability
from state l to state k.
Let's see how we would assign edge weight
for the crooked casino.
In this case, as before, the weight of
edge (l,k,i-1) is to equal to
the product of the corresponding
emission and transition probabilities.
What about this edge?
So the weight of this bold edge,
from state B to state B,
is equal to the emission probability
of emitting symbol H from state B
multiplied by the transition
probability of moving from B to B,
which is 0.75 * 0.9.
And we will continue
further with assigning
the probability of all
edges in a similar fashion,
and afterwards,
we will construct a graph in which
product weight of a hidden path will
be simply equal to the product of
weights of individual edges
as shown on this slide.
For example,
the product weight of this path
will be simply equal to Pr(x,pi).
Therefore, we constructed a graph in
which the product weight of every path
is equal to Pr(x,pi),
exactly what we're interested in.
And therefore,
the computing of Pr(x,pi)
and finding a hidden path pi corresponding
to maximizing Pr(x,pi)
is simply finding a path
with maximum product weight.